A band of lost vikings,
had self for some good pillaging converts to Islam and teaches us all we need to
know about the secrets of the rooms.
You heard that right today.
It's all the runes you can handle first,
learn what rooms are and how the north used them.
Then watch the endless not to explore the history of the word rune and some
surprising ways runes are still relevant to our own tongue.
It's a double dose of runic content onto our story.
Spain,
the early Middle Ages,
the right kind of time and place for the Muslim conquest to drive out the ruling
goths and then for the new ruler to turn around and declare Spain his own
emirate.
But it's also the right kind of time in place for some marauding vikings here,
the come sailing down the coast around eight 40.
And what a vikings do,
give me some words.
They uh,
they raid,
they pillage,
they uh,
they sack.
Yes.
The Norseman sacked Lisbon and then sealed up to savvy.
Yet in eight 44 they attacked,
they start of panic,
and then they held out for weeks waiting for the ransom gold.
When it did arrive,
surprise,
it wasn't gold.
It was a Muslim army ready to crush the vikings and burn their ships.
Try again.
Wait some decades re invade Seville and get slaughtered by more and delusion
forces.
Now,
only ones Raven's know what happens next.
But the story goes that a small band of vikings escaped,
wandered around and settled in southern Spain where they converted to Islam and
became the region's first cheese makers.
The vikings themselves aren't the ones telling us this tail.
No.
We get tales of Viking raids from their victims who wrote in bookish scripts
like Arabic and Latin in Arabic.
They didn't even know what to call them.
So Vikings where Magis Madeye Zoroastrians the Magis weren't just pillaging
Spain.
They had in England and Scotland 50 years earlier,
they stormed Normandy and Paris.
They sacked Ligurian piza founded Bruce in the east.
So there even to think for Russia and Ukraine,
they threatened Constantinople,
were hired to guard Constantinople and let this graffiti in the eye.
Yes,
Sophia,
they even took a Greek holiday to etch rooms into the purees lion near Athens.
Now hold your tiers,
but the loss Viking cheesemakers might just be a legend based on an
interpretation based on an Arabic text.
But that brings up a bigger linguistic question.
Why do we run to Arabic and Latin for our Viking history?
The Norse not know how to write,
meet the rooms.
This is the elder fouth arc.
It's the oldest form of the runes and it works like a full on alphabet.
It's not the ABC's though.
It's a faith arc.
Ooh.
Or these straight line letters.
Perfect for wood and stone are hundreds of years older than the vikings though.
It's hard to say where they come from.
They look a telic,
but what kind of metallic Latin?
Some other old Italk Alphabet,
but the evolved to write early Germanic languages like pro Norse artifacts in
the elder fouth arc are rare,
mostly Scandinavian and all shorts.
Often very short.
This comb is our oldest says Hadiya.
That doesn't mean hair.
That would be funny,
but it's probably a personal name,
personal names,
time after time.
These things say this is my name and I made this like on these Danish golden
horns from the fifth century,
I can lay walk us these whole DOJ made this horn.
But these rooms weren't all about passing information.
Runes offered protection magic words like d was the God too and Tuesday low
cause for garlic and all over the place.
All the Ale.
Oh and in this ale you can see other writing direction wasn't even always left
to right.
So runes had power or in the words of this rune stone master of ruins.
I hide here,
runes of power forever plagued by evil deeds and doomed to insidious death.
Whoever breaks this,
I like it.
Those still aren't Viking rooms.
These are Viking runes.
The faith thought took this shape just a bit before the sacking and pillaging at
the beginning of our story.
This is called the younger fouth arc and it was a big change spot.
The difference at a time with Latin was busy adding letters.
The Norse.
We're actually going backwards in a way.
Cutting letters out.
They got rid of the and go even though they were still pronouncing them now both
to and Kinda had to do double duty.
This happened with a number of letters,
consonants and vowels.
By the way,
these magical runes,
they all have fancy,
dramatic names.
The younger faith arc was short on letters,
but not on scriptions.
Today we only have hundreds of inscriptions in the elder.
Faith are compared to thousands upon thousands in the younger faith arc,
mostly rune stones honoring dead men.
The language of these imposing stones is old Norse and it's already very
different from that proto Norstrom earlier,
younger.
If we thought rune stones,
give us a second look at those ominous seafaring Raiders so despised and feared
by the book.
Any crowd go knee,
raise this stone in memory of or Albany is good son.
He died on the western route or all been involved or had the rooms carved.
He was in Greece.
It was commander of the retinue got raised this stone in memory of Olay fit.
He plowed a stern to the east and met his end in Italy via fostered.
Had this stone raised up in memory of goof moon,
but his brother,
he died in the Abassid caliphate.
May God help his spirit.
Then the end of the Viking age,
Pagan Scandinavia was Christianized,
but were they done with runes?
Not right away.
When King Huddle Bluetooth told the world how we converted the Danes.
He used a rune stone.
Sweden has the greatest concentration of rune stones and many of them are late
and explicitly Christian,
but then watch out.
They're still Thor's hammer.
The Latin alphabet took over and the 11 hundreds when the Norse fully joined the
book and eat club and wrote down their ed does and Sagas but interest in the
runes lingered.
They made a medieval comeback in Codex Rukus for writing Nordic laws.
They even survived in a pocket of Sweden as the Dalit Carlene runes into the 18
hundreds the old runes were terse.
They were short on words,
but rich with names.
They meant kinship,
protection and remembrance to the people that didn't see writing as the
mellifluous prose of Arabic and Latin.
Well at least to the ones that didn't convert to a book and he culture and start
making cheese.
But the Norse weren't the only rune masters around in the first millennium.
Come watch the endless not to explore the etymological twists and turns taken by
rooms and the word ruin itself in the history of English.
Stick around and subscribe for language.